صباح الخير يا باما ، إنها بالتأكيد ليست
حافلة Greyhound ولكن هناك كلاب الصيد فيها
صباح الخير يا جيك لا شيء سوى الكلاب التي
تقفز إلى مقاعدها المخصصة
مرتبطة بالمقاود بدلاً من أحزمة المقاعد التي
تلتقط الركاب المنتظرين مع
Tails صباح الخير
amaru هل ترغب في الحصول على هدية مجانية  الكبد
مع رحلتك بالحافلة ، لم يقل أحد لا
[موسيقى]
جيك
متأكد من أن
البامية هذا
الرئيس أفضل من عذر شركة طيران لأنك
تمتلك بالفعل ملكك ، ويتم تشغيل تحميل رئيس الكلب بواسطة Mo Mountain mutts و
Tiny Skagway Alaska ، إنه فريق زوج
وزوجة يقدمان كلبًا  التدريب
والمشي مع الكلاب ، هل تعرف الكلاب مقعدها الخاص ،
ومعظمهم يفعلون الجراء الجديدة ، فلا
يحاولون القفز في أي مقعد
متاح حتى نعيد ترتيبهم مرة أخرى
إلى ركن الجرو المحظوظ ، ركن الجراء اللعين ،
إنهم عمليًا  تعانق
الحافلة في الجزء الخلفي من الحافلة أثناء الركوب إلى
النزهات ، حيث توفر الحافلة
إمكانية التشابك ، لكن عندما
نشاهدهم ينزلون جيدًا ،
فإنهم يتصرفون بشكل أفضل من  حافلة
من الأطفال لا أستطيع أن أخبرك كم من
هذه الكلاب كانت وحوشًا قبل أن
أبدأ العمل معهم ، هذا هو
الوحش الصغير الخاص بمو طومسون وهو يدق بصوت عالٍ ،
أوه متأكد من أن بعض الركاب هم من قواطع القواعد ،
عفوا سيدتي ، ذيلك
في الممر  سيدتي ، سوف تضطر إلى
ضبط مؤخرتك ولكن هناك مقعد
واحد خارج الحدود
الذي يتحدث عن البوق باما
باما مستعدة لمقايضة رخصة كلبها
للحصول على رخصة قيادة ، عفوا سيدتي ،
أنت لا تقود السيارة وتخرج من مقعدي
genemose CNN مرحبا بالجميع
نيويورك